[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on vient de
le voir votre état le texas ait traversé
donc par des velléités indépendantistes
ça vous surprend vous avez senti cette
colère monte notamment l'élection de joe
biden
why can't we
can a dit à 100 content lorsqu'il a
quitté le parti démocrate
je n'ai pas quitté mon parti c'est le
parti qui m'a quitté
et c'est à ce moment que les démocrates
aux états unis ont arrêté d'être des
patriots et sont devenus un parti
démocrate de gauche internationaliste
socialiste voire communiste et ce parti
ronald reagan ne pouvait plus il
travaillait car cela allait à l'encontre
de ces principes en tant que
l'américain et je pense que le texas en
état ce même point que ronald reagan on
ne peut pas continuer à être ce que le
parti démocrate veut que nous soyons car
le parti démocrate a une idée de du
texas ce qui est totalement en
infraction vis-à-vis de l'histoire
arrêté principe des états unis et donc
il faut se presser et défendre ce que
l'estonie ont toujours été
est ce que le texas fait en ce moment et
j'espère que nous encourageons d'autres
personnes à suivre notre exemple ça veut
dire clairement qu'il y a vous estimez
en tout cas côté que ça s'il ya un vrai
décalage entre ce que vous vous vivez et
le pouvoir de washington
surtout si les démocrates selon vos
besoins
convaincu je pense que c'est une bonne
description l'interface est un endroit
différent un tube la preuve en est le
nombre de personnes qui sont passées que
californie d'autres états de gauche
jusqu'au texas jusqu'en haut clama jusqu
à d'autres états de l'ouest qui ont
cette même image cette même réputation
les mouvements migratoires disent tout
ce qu'il ya à dire sur la californie qui
est trop à gauche et le texas qui est un
lieu accueillant
où les états unis sont toujours tels
qu'ils sont et on respecte toujours là
de la constitution selon vous c'est un
sentiment purement texan ou
ce sentiment et ses velléités
indépendantistes pourraient créer des
émules peut-être dans d'autres bastion
républicain aux états unis
eileen
que le texas est à la pointe d'un
mouvement je ne pense pas qu'on ait
besoin d'un chef d'une pointe à ce
mouvement je pense que plusieurs états
attire les gens
tout simplement par affinités
tu fais du respect pour la constitution
et par l'amérique traditionnel bio ce
n'est pas vraiment l'indépendance texas
textures au texas et le traditionalisme
le respect de la constitution et de
l'histoire américaine le griller date de
plus qu'il ya plus de deux siècles ne
souhaitons pas perdre ce champ ce n'est
pas un désir d'indépendance certains
désirs ne pas perdre ce que nous avions
voici ce qui est le moins l'auteur de ce
mouvement ce qui fait de nous des impôts
dentiste
certaines personnes voudraient que nous
restions
tous solidaires
beaucoup d'états quitte le mouvement
général qu'elle reste fidèle à aux états
unis on en parlait avec notre
correspondant aux états unis à quelques
instants une autre bataille politique
sur le plafond de la dette on entendu
joe biden se plaindre que les
républicains faisait obstruction et
empêcher les démocrates de véritablement
faire leur travail qu'est ce que vous
répondez pour votre défense de
républicains
tout ennemi subissait de beauté il faut
dire autre chose sourit bling pour
démocrates répondent de mensonges dans
les médias c'est une première - fait
aucun vote républicain serait nécessaire
dans les deux chambres pour relever le
plafond de la dette c'est faux les
démocrates entre majorité le cas
d'autres votre à la chambre des
représentants c'est une égalité au sénat
les la vice-présidente
remporte la majorité il pourrait relever
le plafond de la dette celle d'après
midi mais il préfère présenter la
situation quant à les ricains ne tient
donc pas gênant que l'adoption de cette
loi cela permet d'éviter
les reproches après avoir adopté cette
loi préfère donc me voilà deux
préfèrent même que certains public y
voit pour cette loi est tout ensuite
pouvoir valdes quand il faut dire que
c'était une vote
partisan et que donc les conséquences
peuvent être partagées mais cela a
renforcé l'inflation il y aura beaucoup
de conséquences négatives ce sera une
pris de belles choses les deuxièmes
il serait nécessaire de nous retrouver
en défaut de paiement si on ne relevons
pas le plafond de la dette si l'on ne
relève pas le plafond de la dette cela
signifie qu'on ne pas dépenser que se
gagnent au niveau du gouvernement
fédéral et on peut donc continuer à
rembourser les dettes en cours cela ne
signifie pas forcément un défaut de
paiement cela signifie qu'il faudra
ajuster les priorités dans les dépenses
et pas juste et et diminuer certaines
dépenses mais les démocrates était
stimulé les dépenses et adore s'endetter
donc ont pour eux la seule alternative à
relever le plafond de la dette séance et
le défaut de paiement mais ce n'est pas
vrai ils n'ont pas besoin non plus vous
êtes un seul républicain et le défaut de
paiement n'est pas inévitable au touquet
ce sont les deux mensonges répandus dans
les médias merci d perkins à d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous apporter votre point
de vue en direct sur rt franches